a trump campaign Insider told me that
the Santa's campaign is run by dorks for
dorks and I think there's something in
them in that he does the sort of
anti-work thing but he does it rather
robotically he sounds uncomfortable he
looks uncomfortable very often in front
of people he's a bit of an introvert
some people have compared him to Richard
Nixon who obviously was very successful
as the presidential candidate but he
doesn't have that sort of trump wild
Charisma I mean almost nobody does but
he doesn't have a sort of Charisma that
can rival Trump
um and in fact his campaign has sort of
melted upon contact reality because the
key thing about The Campaign which is
him isn't selling very well to the
American public